I give you three characters from Game of
Thrones I knew as Yura tell me when you
would marry them murder them or make out
with them
Robb Stark Jaime Lannister and Theon
Greyjoy married Mirza will make out Robb
Stark Jaime Lannister and Theon Greyjoy
oh god that's really hard about my
brother because I don't want to murder
him but that just leaves incest
I'd marry Jaime Lannister because he
just looks like a ride and a riot to
write nice guys what I meant I would
marry Jaime Lannister I would murder my
avoidance a storm family murder
alright I will make out with my brother
I'm sorry with my family I can't kill
him
sorry guys and I would what would I do
to rob them and murder Rob what have we
done oh ok one more toy win Tywin Tyrion
ordinarius marry murder will make out
Tywin Tyrion and Daenerys marry Tywin
for the power yeah marry Tywin murdered
Tyrion and make out with Daenerys
you know Michelle time I'd surprise you
just wanna kiss Emilia I mean come on so
gorgeous but manager Ian this is just
impossible it's an impossible game a
game that traps to you makes you like it
awful person but this is your armor
though it's okay it's okay it's you he
are aware in an over jumpers terrible
merry murder or makeout final choice now
John Snow
samwell tarly and Ygritte Jon Snow
Samwell Tarly in Ygritte Mary murder or
make outs the choice is yours as you're
a Greyjoy Mary Samwell make out with Jon
Snow murder Ygritte so white white white
reassured me that I'm me are making
these decisions I'm like yeah definitely
definitely those things so marrying Sam
well that comes from I really like Jon
actually you know this jammer we're
gonna making the decision there Jon
Jon's a good boy yeah that I love kid oh
god it's just as I say it's impossible
game you try playing at home you can't
just want to make out with everyone
ready
it's the truth don't you murder and
marrying is to committed and murder is
awful but you know make out with
everyone is what I would like to be
saying here but they're forcing me but I
really say I was gonna make out with my
brother of course
it's game it frightens everyone speaking
out their brother everyone's I say all
night so I don't feel so bad
that was pretty thank you so much Jomo
bye guys